what we really need here is a network
utility people get their highway bill
every month like they get their electric
bill and their water bill on their cell
phone bill they're paying for what they
use and only what they use
i am nick gillespie with reason we're
talking with Bob all he's the Searle
freedom trust fellow and director of
transportation policy of Reason
Foundation and we're talking about
Donald Trump's transportation policies
or likely transportation policies and
whether or not they're good for
libertarians are from a libertarian
perspective Bob thanks for talking to us
glad to be here name so what is the
essence of trumps transportation policy
as he really kind of articulated a plan
and where do you think he's heading what
we know so far as they talked a lot
about crumbling infrastructure and need
to make America's infrastructure great
again so this suggests a big new
emphasis in some kind of a federal is it
by the way is that accurate is our
infrastructure crumbling yeah that's a
big exaggeration I mean we do reports on
this at Reason Foundation and and if you
look at for example deficient
structurally deficient bridges that has
trended downward sharply over the last
two decades there's still quite a few
you know hundreds of them actually a few
thousand of them out there but it's
gotten much less bad but there's no
question no question use new roads more
risk well the interstate highway system
the first ones built are past their
50-year service life and few of them
have actually been replaced with fresh
pavement and new bridges there's a
trillion dollars worth just alone over
the next 20 or 30 years in replacement
Hillary at one point talked about
creating something like a five hundred
billion restructure bank and then Trump
said oh you know what I'm going to
double that well there's actually two
Trump numbers that are out there one is
550 billion that's repeatedly seen in
news articles the other is a trillion
dollars which is the plan developed by
wilbur ross and investment banker and
peter navarro is an economist at UC san
diego and that's a ten page document
that is a public-private partnership is
that 550 billion or the trillion dollars
is that all coming out of taxpayer money
or no well the 550 billion we don't
really have a clue that is imply that
that's out of some kind of tax reform
and possibly repatriation of overseas
profits that would be a one-time catch
up sort of big investment thing but the
the other the trillion-dollar plan from
wilbur ross and peter navarro is a p3
public-private partnership plan that
the only federal involvement in that
other than Congress authorizing it would
be a tax credit for the equity investors
but these would be like the p3 projects
that we're seeing in Virginia and Texas
and Florida typically financed about
twenty five percent by equity that hard
like a down payment on a house and
seventy-five percent by debt the revenue
bonds and it is the when you say revenue
bond that explain how that's different
than this state just right the revenue
bond has to be backed by a user fee
revenue stream so this would be tolls
water bills electricity transmission
fees whatever something like that so I
mean this plan is bigger than many
people expected if it goes forward but
it's also more narrowly constrained
because you'd have to have you customer
user fees in places like most of the
interstates where we don't have them
today so that becomes a big political ?
and would you be a will to do that would
that would that get rid of kind of gas
taxes or taxes that traditionally or
supposed to be earmarked no it wouldn't
get rid of it because I that would be
more radical than anybody in Congress
would be prepared to do or the state do
tease but it would the way without
increasing the federal gas taxes a way
to have a big increase in infrastructure
investment based on an increase in user
fee revenues direct user to talk a
little bit about the massive amount of
capital that is out there all over the
globe to get to these giant
infrastructure programs at a point where
there isn't a state in the country and
certainly the federal government has you
know a lot of money to blow up right
right well they growth globally for the
last 15 years ISM to growth of
infrastructure investment funds some of
them run by investment banks some of
them run by sovereign wealth funds some
of the run by by private equity firms
that kind of do corporate takeovers and
so forth they've amassed big portfolios
of money and they're looking globally
worldwide at airports electric
transmission lines water and wastewater
systems toll roads and so forth as
places to invest equity and to finance
these public-private partnership either
outright purchases and ownership or
long-term lease concessions
public-private partnerships that maybe
50 year duration that are financed by
the equity down payment
revenue bonds that they would issue is
there a political understanding or a
sense of crisis that okay yeah we really
do need to be doing something about
infrastructure yeah there and then is
there is there a political will to say
you know what we're going to bring in
yeah outside investors and shift this is
kind of like the shift from free TV to
get right right it's this is a big
question we don't know the house TNI
Committee on a bipartisan basis about
two years ago this was under shoes
trencherman Shuster initiative did a
six-month project they had a task force
of some of their members on
public-private partnerships and the role
they could play in transportation
infrastructure and it was a pretty good
report now the question is did the
members who signed on to that from both
parties really understand what they were
endorsing and are they prepared be
prepared to have the federal government
bless and encourage a much larger scale
use of those mechanisms talk about
Obama's transportation policy as a kind
of contrast with what definitely big
contrast I mean first one was he was
going to do do an Eisenhower analog of
the interstate highways with a
nationwide high-speed rail dream well
that was completely foolish and has
basically got nowhere the only part
standing is the ridiculous California
boondoggle that is now with the
republican takeover is not going to get
any more federal money and they can't
find any other real state money and no
private sector companies are willing to
invest in it so that one that's dead
Obama's repeated every almost every year
of his eight years he put in a proposal
proposed transportation bill that would
have a big increase in in spending
without an increase in revenue sources
and would convert the Highway Trust Fund
which has a small piece twenty percent
for transit into a transportation trust
fund so that every boat Amtrak could tap
into it a boondoggle projects on
waterways you know maritime highways
could tap into it and so on and so forth
that ever got a hearing even in Congress
but he tried it again and again and
again so that's that's now dead and
buried who are some of the people you
know and I know you've been talking to
people
Trump is again early in the trend
priceless and whatnot but is talking to
and are they do they give you hope or do
they give you a little bit you know kind
of night sweat I'm encouraged by what I
see first of all the the person heading
the the team in in the transition for
the USDOT is surely y bar my former
reason colleague who was the secretary
of transportation in virginia and where
she came up with and God implemented the
public private transportation act the
blueprint for p3 projects in Virginia
which has become a model for other
states to follow shirley was also part
of a business roundtable task force on
air traffic control corporation of take
pulling that out of FAA and setting it
up as a self funding corporation the
main benefit of taking air traffic
control away from a government agency to
a corporate you know where the airline's
themselves are running in be a bunch of
benefits as a bureaucracy that's
dependent on annual appropriations based
on aviation user tax revenue this money
every year has to be appropriated by
Congress and Congress loves to
micromanage that if you're doing
multi-billion dollar capital
modernization and you have no idea from
one year to the next what they're going
to appropriate what they're going to
veto this plays havoc with it says
that's why our air traffic control
system really basically lags behind
Canada Britain Australia New Zealand and
a number of other countries that have
created air traffic corporations and got
it out of the political they
depoliticized it beyond safety measures
it also it increases the number of
planes I can fly and write it maximizes
the use of it I mean right now
technology is what constrains how many
planes can be in a given amount of
airspace more accurate real-time
information means you can make more
intense safely make use more intensive
use of the airspace so this is something
that seems very consistent with what
we're seeing about user fee financing
and so forth I hope this becomes a
priority for the Trump administration
but what will depend on who become
Secretary of Transportation final
question talk a little bit about user
fees because I'm hearing my my liberal
and progressive friends saying like oh
you know what now the corporations are
going to own the roads and what about
poor people how to the
work get around if they're living in a
world where every time they write hit
the road or go you know that they're
paying out well people are they're
paying out now every time they put gas
in their car and the question is can we
come up with a better system that's
actually more transparent and more
accountable to the users and I've
written a book that's now we hope
nearing to a publisher contract on a
model for 21st century highways that
says look what we really need here is a
network utility that people get their
Trent their highway bill every month
like they get their electric bill and
their water bill on their cell phone
bill they know exactly they're paying
for what they use and only what they use
their not subsidizing all kinds of other
projects that they never see or never
use I would assume for people who can't
afford or low-income people you can help
them with a cash grant that I mean the
same way we do we don't say because some
people can't afford food we're actually
if we give it some get food stamps and
and what we should have been doing all
along instead of subsidizing transit
agencies is giving the poor or transit
vouchers and allowing them to spend them
and the transit system could then price
everybody else at what it really costs
to to pay for the capital and as well as
the operating cost of the system I will
leave Bob this it's always good to talk
to you in a transportation is
fascinating when you were growing up
what what was your what did you hope for
as a mode of transportation when you're
the age you are now what's it you know
was it a personal backpack a hovercraft
well my uncle actually was in the
transport Army Transportation Research
command and he always sending me things
about hovercrafts and jet packs they
were they tried all that stuff and it
didn't it didn't really pan out but
actually I grew up in an Eastern
Airlines household and so we flew
everywhere on company passes so what I
really wanted was I didn't know it at
the time but I wanted was airline
deregulation because because Eastern
when I was a kid uh applied for the
route from Miami where I grew up to Los
Angeles and didn't get it and so that
when Disneyland opened we couldn't go
because we no way my parents get more
than take the whole family on a
commercial flights at commercial prices
that were very high in those days so by
very first published article in recent
magazine
in 1969 was advocating airline
deregulation inspired by that childhood
now I trust that you've gone to have you
been to this hype into Disneyland and
Disney World in Florida both multiple
occasions alright well we'll leave it
there thanks so much thank you for
reason i'm nick gillespie
[Music]